the new england patriots watching
intently what the bills do tonight
because they are now two and three first
time below 500
this late in the season since
2001 or at least five games into the
season since two that now 2001 worked
out pretty well and you know what this
could be a team like 2001 where they get
better on the fly
but are we worried should we be worried
about new england is there a fundamental
difference between this team and other
editions of the patriots that that is
more than just the inconveniences
they've experienced because of the
pandemic
i think you should be worried mike i
think you had him going to the super
bowl right nobody cares about that
nobody cares about that that's what we
do
because here's the thing when you get it
right it's not like they show up at your
house with a new car right you got lucky
that's so yeah i i had the buccaneers
and the patriots and until
one or both are mathematically
eliminated i'm sticking with that pick
but but anyway uh our should we really
be concerned about the the possibility
of the page just getting to the playoffs
much less advancing to the super bowl
yeah
well this is a team mic i was concerned
about before the year even started
because of all the coveted opt-outs they
had had i just didn't know how they were
going to put all this together and hey
bill belichick is the greatest coach in
the history of the game the packers can
argue otherwise the steelers can argue
otherwise you can have all those
arguments but bill belichick is the
greatest coach to ever coach in this
league
but you have to have talent and i think
it showed on
yesterday that they don't have the
talent they once did uh cam newton
cannot carry this team not practicing i
understand hurt this team but you just
look at where they're ranked and how
he's done he has more interceptions than
touchdowns two touchdowns four
interceptions he's
down near the bottom in in paso rating
mediocre and offense mediocre and
defense 14th and and 9th
this to me is just a mediocre team they
scream out mediocre just with the talent
they have they have the coaching i just
don't think they have anything to go
along with the coaching and now
certainly in our next segment we're
going to even question the coaching and
some of the things that bill belichick
did in that game yesterday but yes i
think this is a team very much that's
going to struggle to make the playoffs
despite the added playoff team
i'm not going to make excuses for the
patriots because they would be the last
ones to make excuses for themselves i
thought they'd be the last time that the
last team to have any covet issues
because i just assumed everything would
be buttoned up as well as it could be
and of all the people on the team to be
their patient zero for to be cam newton
really was stunning and it tells me that
something in the messaging
to cam newton didn't work otherwise he
wouldn't have gotten it i know he's on
radio today saying he didn't know how he
got it well he got it doesn't matter
heavy you don't know how you got it you
got it you did something to expose
yourself to it so you weren't as
buttoned up as you needed to be and that
information is being provided to players
by most teams if not all teams the
question is are you hearing it are you
heeding it and are the people who are
communicating it's sufficiently
sensitive to whether or not guys really
do get it the patriots have always been
very good about sending messages that
are always
carefully followed or else by every
member of the organization and that's
what surprises me that they're one of
the teams that's had this issue that
they're a team that desperately needs to
be practicing needs to be developing
needs to be gelling and they've lost
those opportunities and cam newton was
gone for three weeks and last week they
barely practiced the week before they
barely practiced they've got offensive
linemen on the coveted list they've got
injured offensive lineman they don't
have dante scarneckia there to make
chicken salad out of whatever the
quality of the five guys who are able to
play may be and it's just starting to
show up and even then even then
they still almost beat the broncos they
still almost won the game it was ugly
and the broncos had way too many field
goals
not enough or any touchdowns they could
have blown the patriots off the field
the patriots defense held up its end of
the bargain the offense is going to have
to do more or eventually the the defense
is just going to break it's it's
not going to be able to take it anymore
and they've still got some tough games
coming up and they've got to play the
bills twice they have the bills two
weeks from now um they've still i'm not
writing them off because they have bill
belichick because they have josh
mcdaniels and because they have cam
newton here's cam from earlier today
talking about what he needs to do to
better lead his new team
i have to be better i want to make that
perfectly clear you know i have to play
better football for the new england
patriots and i will i think any
competitor
in this position you know
i i heard a person say once you know i
don't point fingers you know i point
thumbs
and with that being said i take full
responsibility of where we are as
offense and and knowing here moving
forward that i will it starts with
number one
and i will be better not not and that
doesn't mean
i'm gonna do more and and impress the
issue it's just you know doing the small
better and i think i can do a better job
i like that saying i mean you still can
point a thumb at someone else it just
looks weird um but i like that i don't
point fingers i point thumbs and and
that's how the patriots have always been
and and and that'll be the ultimate test
of the patriot way shireen they're
dealing with adversity they've dealt
with adversity they figure it all out
and they put their best foot forward and
this is a team that's always on the next
week on to the next challenge and maybe
they'll be a lot better if they can
eradicate the covet from the building
and practice three times a week and cam
newton can continue to develop and i've
always thought they're going to be
better later in the year they're just
going to be better later than they
otherwise would have been because of
what's happened the last couple of weeks
completely agree mike this is a team
that is going to get better i think
they're good enough to beat anybody when
you go back and look at that seattle
game that to me was probably the most
encouraging sign for the patriots to be
honest it came down to one play on the
goal line and they could have won that
game and that's against what we think is
a really good team so i think that's the
encouraging thing for him the victory
over the raiders was good so i think
they're good enough to beat anybody but
at the same time i think they're bad
enough to lose to anybody i mean the
broncos game when you start penciling
and l's and w's was a game they should
have won they didn't win that game
whether we were letting them off the
hook or not for coveted whether that
played a part or not whatever that's
still a game you should go out and win
you look at what the titans did when
they came off of their big break came
out and they looked terrific and they
they just didn't miss a beat maybe it
was all those off-site workouts who
knows but
they played really well and the patriots
failed to do that and when i look at
their schedule i see the jets on their
twice i know those are two
wins what should be wins i don't know
about the rest of their games i think
they should beat houston but after
losing to denver i don't know and then
the other games in there you feel like
they're probably not going to be favored
in those games
yeah they've got three games left left
against the teams of the nfc east and
they start this weekend late afternoon
game hosting the 49ers then it's at
buffalo at the jets on a monday night oh
boy schedule something else that night
and then on a sunday night the baltimore
ravens come to town so three of the next
four games should be tough ones for the
new england patriots and i think they
need to win three they need to go three
and one over the next four to
re-establish themselves and we'll see if
they can do it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports